[Music]
on this Tuesday night what soldiers
discovered inside five Ontario long-term
care homes
I think it's appalling I think it's
disgusting why did it take the military
to expose gruesome conditions and
shameful neglect no matter what it takes
we're gonna fix this system as Quebec
care homes already struggling are now
sweltering in a heatwave suspended by
Canadian clinical trials of
hydroxychloroquine are now on pause and
game on the NHL's timeline to power
forward during the pandemic
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
across this country for weeks now
Canadians have been banned from visiting
their loved ones inside long-term care
homes unable to see for themselves
what's going on inside now the Canadian
military has painted a dreadful picture
of conditions inside some of them the
premieres of Ontario and Quebec were so
desperate last month they asked soldiers
to deploy into homes unable to cope with
kovat 19 outbreaks now the military has
issued a report into five homes in
Ontario the 15 page report contains
allegations of terrible neglect and lack
of hygiene here are just some of them
little or no disinfection significant
gross fecal contamination was noted in
numerous patient rooms nurses PSWs often
observed not changing PPE for several
hours while moving between numerous
patient rooms general culture of fear to
use supplies because they cost money
fluid bags dressings gowns gloves
forceful feeding observed by staff
causing audible choking and aspiration
patients observed crying for help with
staff not responding for 30 minutes to
over two hours the reports they provided
us were heartbreaking they were horrific
it's shocking that this can happen here
in Canada the Ontario government is
responsible for inspecting the
facilities so why did it take the
military to expose how grim the
situation was here's how premier Ford
answered that question yes inspections
happen but it took the military to be
there 24/7 every single day that's when
you find out there's cracks in the
system by living the system around the
clock every single day Ontario's
long-term care Minister says her
government was working on fixing
long-standing cracks in the system and
then the pandemic hit and the situation
she says became a full-blown crisis
Colvin tipped the homes that were having
difficulties with staffing already right
over the edge Canadians cannot tolerate
this
we need all levels of government to come
together
Mercedes Stevenson joins me from Ottawa
Mercedes why did the military write this
report and send it up the chain of
command Donna the Department of National
Defense says that the troops raised
these concerns because they are trained
to report anything that potentially
jeopardizes their mission or could harm
Canadians who they serve after an
initial report was submitted to Ottawa
on May 14th many troops became concerned
as days passed on without action they
were concerned that nothing would be
done and vulnerable seniors in these
homes with no ability to speak out would
face the same disturbing conditions
troops allege they found them in one
military source described those
conditions as quote worse than anything
I've seen overseas here are just some of
the conditions that troops allege they
found happening in Ontario care homes
abuse of residence falsifying of medical
documents kovat 19 patients not being
properly isolated new workers who were
not trained and a blatant disregard or
lack of knowledge of how to wear
personal protective equipment and how to
execute infection control measures at
Hawthorn place care center troops
reported a cockroach infestation and
forceful feeding that caused residents
to audibly choke and aspirate at
Eatonville care center troops reported
alleged abusive and inappropriate
treatment of residents including when
changing their incontinence products
troops report that regular staff at the
home stopped them from going into
patients rooms to clean or see patients
at Holland Christian homes allegations
of abuse and neglect the military
described patients dying in what they
called unnecessary pain troops also said
food was left in a residence mouth while
sleeping and that staff did not help
residents to eat instead writing down
that they refused food all of this is
raising concerns for families who have
seniors in homes and those who will soon
enter those homes themselves about how
Canada treats our elderly think of the
the people living in long-term care now
who are seeing this on television who
are still in long-term care who can't
talk to their families don't have
outside
that interaction this is just going to
add to that anxiety in that concern
Mercedes this is agonizing for residents
and for family members who can't go
inside these homes and be advocates for
their loved ones premiere Ford raised
the possibility today of criminal
charges and promised accountability and
justice is that just rhetoric Donna
there is a possibility of criminal
charges in a at least one of the cases
potentially of course these are reports
that will have to go to the police who
will make those decisions one example
that stood out to us at orchard villa a
patient died allegedly choking to death
after being fed while lying down flat
that's something the troops flagged as
being deeply concerning that incident
has now been referred to the coroner's
office and the premier address to today
others say lack of training is an issue
not just a problem with intentions and
the Union tonight pushing back the union
representing workers at two of the care
homes that we mentioned say that they
welcomed the report from the military
but that they have been ringing alarm
bells throughout the entire crisis
saying unfortunately we have had to
fight the provincial government every
step of the way to ensure long-term care
companies are keeping workers and
residents safe
Mercedes this report is about five homes
in Ontario where the military is
deployed they're also in 13 long-term
care homes in Quebec which has had the
most deaths from kovat 19 is there a
similar report coming on Quebec so I've
asked the military and they haven't said
clearly but I would imagine that there
will be a demand to see this Donna
people will want to know what's going on
there and keep in mind the larger effect
right now there are 39 troops who have
been diagnosed with kovat 19 and many
more still working in the homes Donna
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
the first heat wave of the year in
Ontario and Quebec is making conditions
inside many long-term care homes even
more challenging temperatures soared to
over 30 degrees Celsius today in some
places it's forecast to stay hot for the
next few days Mike Armstrong explains
what that means for residents and staff
especially inside older facilities that
have no central air conditioning
when this seniors residence on
Montreal's west island was built in 1908
air conditioning barely existed well for
most of the residents
it still doesn't staff tells us it's
getting hotter and hotter and yet the
one place to go outside to cool off is
off-limits
this is inhumane I don't know how much
I'm going to have to repeat that it is
inhumane unacceptable there are
estimates that only 25 to 35% of
residents in Quebec long term care
facilities have air-conditioning newer
buildings tend to have central air but
then you also have buildings like this
one in Montreal's East End it's dealt
with heat waves but very rarely in May
this heat wave is hitting very very
early in the season this buildings about
a hundred years old it only has a few
air conditioners down on this level when
a heat wave normally hits in the summer
there would be dozens of air
conditioners sticking out of windows
where the residents sleep that hasn't
happened yet there are dozens and dozens
here still in storage the staff at
facilities usually use air-conditioned
common areas to cool residents down
that's not always possible right now due
to kovat 19 with movement restricted
even just opening windows and getting
air flowing through the building is
problematic
they don't want potentially contaminated
air passing from one area to another
it's gonna be more complicated this year
Health Minister insists the government
has been working on solutions possibly
mobile air conditioners but says this
early heat wave hit before they were
ready now for staff a rough situation is
getting rougher they're going through
this heatwave in masks visors gowns and
gloves it's stifling people under all
that protective gear are gonna need lots
of water and some breaks now this heat
wave is also affecting the general
public people without air-conditioning
are usually told to go to places like
malls those are closed or community
pools that's not an option right now
either Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal there's been much debate about
the anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine president Trump said
he was taking it but says he's now
stopped he still calls it tremendous
there is evidence though
it's not research published in the
lancet showed an increased risk of death
and the World Health Organization has
temporarily halted trials to determine
if it's a safe and effective treatment
for kovat 19 Canada was taking part in
that trial at a Urich's West explains
why it's been suspended there are
concerns that hydroxychloroquine may be
doing kovat 19 patients more harm than
good the executive group has implemented
a temporary pause of the hydroxyl
hydroxychloroquine arm within the
Solidarity trial while the data the
safety data is reviewed 35 countries
including Canada had been recruiting
patients for the trial at 30 hospitals
across the country although no Canadian
trial participants had been given the
anti malaria medication yet mostly it's
related to some emerging evidence not
from randomised controlled trials which
are the gold standard but from
observational studies suggesting that
there may be some harm associated or
induce in hospitalized patients with
mid-nineteen that evidence was published
last week in The Lancet it found that
after reviewing 96,000 virus patients
across six continents there was a higher
risk of abnormal heartbeats that could
cause heart attacks among those treated
with hydroxychloroquine the problem with
this analysis in the observational study
in The Lancet is that without
randomizing patients the
hydroxychloroquine are no
hydroxychloroquine um the assumption is
that sicker patients will likely get
more medications and it's impossible to
control for that a trial safety
committee will now review all of the
data that has been collected within the
randomized control trial so far to
determine whether hydroxychloroquine has
been causing harm that review is
expected to take two weeks there's not
harm then we'll continue as I still
might possibly be benefit associated
with a second Canadian trial out of the
University of Calgary has also been
suspended pending further review Heather
Eric's West Global News Calgary towtruck
turf war coming up how Ontario police
say they put the brakes on an organised
crime
police in Ontario have laid hundreds of
charges after an investigation into turf
wars between tow truck operators
investigators believe competition for
market control led to property damage
and serious violence even murder
Catherine MacDonald is following the
story for us
Catherine donut York Regional Police
north of Toronto have charged 20 people
and could be arresting dozens more after
allegedly dismantling an organized crime
ring involving arrival tow truck
companies over the past two years police
across the Greater Toronto Area have
responded to dozens of calls for
suspicious fires involving tow trucks
and many more violent incidents
involving tow truck operators York
Regional Police have now arrested 20
people including the owner of Paramount
towing also known as prestige towing and
employees of other rival towing groups
alleged organized criminals who police
say are fighting over turf we allege
that the competition for control of the
towing market has resulted in murders
attempted murders shootings assaults
arsons threats and property damage
apparently motivated by greed the tow
truck drivers arrested allegedly
inflated costs and victimized consumers
police say the accused also deliberately
caused collisions with unsuspecting
drivers and staged collisions using
drivers they'd hired before making
fraudulent claims investigators have
confirmed the tow companies collaborated
with auto repair shops and physiotherapy
clinics as well as car and truck rental
companies to carry out their frauds
police say a law firm that was hired by
an insurance company to investigate
these fraudulent claims was also
targeted starting in January 2019 when
someone tried to set the firm on fire
months later an employee was threatened
at gunpoint and last September shots
were fired through the front window of
the business also amongst the charges
two counts of first degree murder for
the shooting death of tow truck drivers
so he'll rafa poor in December 2018 the
three-month joint force investigation
with the Toronto Police the Ontario
Provincial Police and the Canadian
Revenue Agency dubbed Project platinum
culminated last Wednesday when
twenty-one search warrants were executed
resulting in the seizure of 40 firearms
ammunition two million dollars worth of
illicit drugs and half a million dollars
in cash we are in the process of
dismantling four distinct criminal
organizations through these arrests and
those to come police believe there will
be less violence here in the Greater
Toronto Area as a result of these
arrests and are now calling on the
provincial government to regulate the
towtruck industry to prevent future
violence Donna Katherine MacDonald in
Toronto thanks ahead China's stern
warning to Canada as huawei CFO braces
for a court decision
PPE is at the core of a scandal emerging
around digital government Minister Joyce
Murray Global News has learned a WeChat
social media group run on behalf of the
BC Liberal MP was used to crowdsource
funding for a lawsuit against a global
news journalist last month our
investigation exposed troubling details
about China's state back effort to
stockpile coronavirus safety supplies
during the early days of the Cova 19
outbreak the fundraising appeal led to
this exchange in the House of Commons
today the minister has admitted that her
taxpayer-funded political aide is the
one who manages her WeChat account and
allowed the fundraising campaign to be
promoted clearly this is inappropriate
what action has the Prime Minister taken
in this in light of these revelations
attacking the integrity of hard-working
journalists is absolutely unacceptable
the individual who posted this link on
this particular group is no longer a
member of this group and is not
affiliated with the electoral district
Association in question
Joyce Murray's communication team says
the WeChat post was unacceptable and in
no way reflects the minister's views it
says the Vancouver MP uses the platform
to engage members of a Chinese Canadian
community canada's tense relationship
with china could be further tested by a
court ruling in Vancouver tomorrow the
BC Supreme Court is set to rule on the
extradition case of Huawei executive ma
Wan Jo she was arrested in Canada in
2018 at the request of the United States
accused of violating sanctions against
Iran China is keeping up the pressure on
Canada to release mung Abigail Beaman
explains what's at stake
on the eve of a BC judge's decision that
could set ma Wan Jo free ruling whether
what she's accused of in the United
States would be considered a crime in
Canada comes a stern warning from China
one decision Canada should immediately
release her he says to avoid further
damage to China Canada relations one of
the good things about having a truly
independent justice system is that we
don't need to apologize or explain for
the decisions taken a complicated moment
for China Canada relations which have
already been stretched for some time
Hmong the detainment of Canadians
Michael Kohlberg and Michael spa or
widely viewed as retaliation trade
issues a decision on 5g still pending
and Canada's concern for its citizens in
Hong Kong this weekend China's embassy
in Ottawa condemned Canada's joint
statement on proposed national security
legislation in Hong Kong saying we
deplore and strongly oppose what it sees
as meddling we see what what the Chinese
are referring to as wolf warrior
diplomacy where Chinese representatives
abroad and the foreign ministry
spokesman jolly Jin are making a
statements which are outrageously
aggressive and really amounting to a
form of disinformation has been dealt a
very tough hand director of the China
Institute Gordon Holden points out the
Hmong case isn't just about tough
bilateral relations we're caught between
Washington and Beijing that
relationships deteriorating rapidly
especially in an election year in United
States if mangoes free Holden says the
US won't be pleased if she doesn't brace
for a long appeals process the case
could drag on for years still with no
betterment of the Canada China
relationship in sight
Abigail Beeman Global News Ottawa
next life after kovat 19 what it's like
for those who have recovered
the NHL is getting closer to getting
back on the ice it's still not exactly
clear when though NHL commissioner Gary
Bettman announced today the regular
season is over and 24 teams will head
straight to the playoffs they would play
in two hub cities one for the Eastern
Conference and one for the West those
hub cities have yet to be determined but
Edmonton Toronto and Vancouver are on
the shortlist the NHL plan still needs
the green light from government and
public health officials a decision will
depend on what's happening with the
pandemic right now there are some signs
of improvement
Canada has had more than 86,000
confirmed cases of kovat 19 and more
than half of those people have now
recovered it's possible they could have
some immunity to the virus
Jeff's simple explains I didn't leave my
house for over a month and I go out in
the world is completely different now
Kyla Leigh is one of the recovered
global national first spoke with the
Vancouver lawyer in early April when she
was in self quarantine with kovat 19 to
be plagued with a fever for two weeks a
call for over two weeks but today so how
are you feeling now great totally back
to normal
albe 'it a new normal Leigh stepped
outside to find a society gripped with
anxiety while knowing she likely doesn't
need to worry but I am i think probably
taking more risks than other people
would as far as like when I'm out in
public just because I am likely immune
a made in Italy blood test just approved
by Health Canada will be deployed in the
coming weeks to help determine whether a
patient has been infected and developed
antibodies against kovat 19 and as
economies reopen some businesses are
deploying new technology to separate the
recovered from the rest this smartphone
software is one of a growing number of
so-called immunity passports the
technology already deployed in some
European countries is used to identify
those who've tested positive for
antibodies so they can go back to work
any and all tools that will help get
life back to normal and save lives
should be used unsurprisingly immunity
passports are also sparking a slew of
scientific and ethical concerns and
experts aren't sure whether the
recovered will remain immune so we don't
know what the expiry date should be so
the idea is seems useful
it seems attractive but without an
expiry date we just don't know how long
that is safe but there is a growing push
to deploy the proof of antibodies
technology in certain situations such as
screening incoming international
travelers and frontline care workers
where the need is greatest Geoff sample
Global News Toronto and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
Friesen we leave you tonight with this
little hoot actually three of them and
they're pretty big the Belgian man in
this apartment first thought the noise
from his window boxes pigeons turns out
it was Europe's largest owl the Eurasian
Eagle Owl and the three chicks now have
a perfect view of his TV which they
watched together take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]